Traduttore: Roberto Minelli
Revisore: Michele Gianella
“Sa di polvere da sparo”
si diceva, nell’aprile 1972,
l'astronauta dell'Apollo 16, Charlie Duke.
Era appena rientrato
da una passeggiata sulla luna;
un po' di polvere lunare
gli era rimasta attaccata
alla tuta spaziale
e questa polvere aveva invaso
l'abitacolo dell'Apollo 16
e lui l’aveva, inavvertitamente,
assaggiata e odorata.
Vorrei partire da questa testimonianza
molto insolita - rarissima -
per parlarvi dell'universo,
in particolare di come
percepiamo l'universo
e di come questa percezione stia cambiando
grazie alle scoperte
della cosmologia moderna
e dell'astronomia moderna.
Ora, noi abbiamo
cinque sensi a disposizione
ma, se ci pensate bene,
utilizziamo soltanto la vista
per conoscere l'universo.
Questo un po' è scontato:
non possiamo certo pensare
di andare a toccare, o assaggiare,
gli asteroidi, le stelle e i pianeti.
Anche l'odorato e l'udito
non ci aiutano certo molto,
per conoscere l'universo:
sono limitati a piccole distanze
e, in ogni caso,
a questo piccolo guscio di atmosfera
che c'è intorno alla Terra.
Ci resta soltanto la vista.
Il fatto di riuscire a vedere l'universo
è meno scontato di quanto possa sembrare.
Da una parte, è vero che i nostri occhi -
gli occhi degli esseri umani -
sono, in un certo senso,
fatti per vedere le stelle.
Sono degli organi
che si sono sviluppati
nel corso dell'umanità
per raccogliere e analizzare la luce
che ci viene dalla stella
che è più vicina a noi, il Sole.
Però, è anche vero
che potremmo vivere, per esempio,
come nel racconto “Nightfall” di Asimov,
su un pianeta con molti soli,
in cui è sempre giorno
e gli abitanti di quel pianeta
non sono a conoscenza
dell'esistenza delle stelle.
Potremmo vivere su un pianeta come Venere,
coperto sempre da nubi;
oppure sotto la superficie
ghiacciata di un pianeta,
come delle ipotetiche forme di vita
sul satellite Europa di Giove.
Eppure, quindi,
possiamo considerarci fortunati,
in un certo senso,
di poter godere ogni notte
di questo grande spettacolo
del cielo stellato.
Ed è proprio grazie all'osservazione
di questo cielo stellato
che i nostri antenati hanno cominciato
a conoscere l'universo,
osservando a occhio nudo le stelle.
E gli allineamenti
dei grandi monumenti dell'antichità
ci testimoniano come questo sia qualcosa
che l'umanità ha fatto da sempre.
Abbiamo utilizzato il sorgere
e il tramontare delle costellazioni
come un calendario,
un grande calendario astronomico
che ci aiutava a gestire
il raccolto, la semina.
E abbiamo lentamente cominciato
a distinguere i pianeti dalle stelle;
abbiamo capito che la Terra
è un pianeta che gira intorno al Sole;
abbiamo imparato a descrivere le leggi
che governano il movimento dei pianeti;
e, in particolare,
abbiamo capito la forza di gravità,
che è la forza che regola, praticamente,
l'universo sulle grandi scale.
A partire da Galileo in poi
abbiamo cominciato a percepire
l'universo profondo
grazie ai telescopi, che sono
delle sorte di occhi artificiali,
dei nuovi organi di senso,
degli occhi artificiali
che ci permettono di percepire
degli oggetti celesti,
delle stelle, delle galassie
che sarebbero altrimenti
invisibili all'occhio umano.
E, allo stesso tempo, ci siamo resi conto
che esistono tanti altri
colori nell'universo,
dei colori che sono
invisibili all'occhio umano.
Potremmo, anzi, raccontare
la storia dell'astronomia
come un lungo viaggio
alla scoperta dei colori
che sono invisibili all'occhio umano.
E abbiamo quindi -
se voi prendete il rosso
e il blu, su questo palco,
questa è luce, lo stesso tipo di luce;
c'è una piccola differenza di energia,
dell'ordine del 30 percento,
ma lo spettro della luce
è molto, molto più ampio.
E quindi, con l'astronomia,
a partire dagli anni trenta del 1900,
abbiamo cominciato a studiare
questi colori invisibili all'occhio umano
e abbiamo cominciato
a costruire degli strumenti
che ci permettevano di osservare
dall'infrarosso alle microonde,
alle onde radio.
E via via abbiamo cominciato
a studiare l'universo
anche alle più alte energie:
ai raggi X, ai raggi gamma.
Abbiamo scoperto un universo
assolutamente incredibile,
un universo popolato di cose strane:
ci sono delle stelle, come le Pulsar,
che sono dense e compatte,
girano intorno a sé stesse
in una frazione di secondo;
abbiamo scoperto il Quasar,
dei buchi neri giganteschi
che sputano dei getti
di energia e di materia
nello spazio intergalattico.
Ma quanto è grande, allora, l'universo?
E che cosa c'è là fuori?
Primo Levi, un grande scrittore -
che era anche uno scienziato, peraltro -
scrisse nel suo libro
“Se questo è un uomo”
che la natura umana
è nemica di ogni infinito.
È difficile, per noi,
concepire l'immensità del cosmo.
E quello che vorrei fare
è di provare a fare un piccolo esperimento
per aiutarvi a visualizzare l'universo
come lo possono visualizzare
gli astronomi.
E vorrei partire da questa immagine:
questa è una fotografia vera
scattata da una sonda della NASA,
la sonda Osiris, pochi mesi fa.
Quello che vedete
al centro di questa immagine
è il nostro pianeta: è la Terra.
Quel minuscolo disco
che sembra perso in un universo,
in uno spazio completamente vuoto,
è il pianeta su cui si è svolta
l'intera storia dell'umanità.
In basso a destra vedete la luna.
Il diametro di quest'orbita,
dell'orbita della luna,
è di circa un miliardo di metri -
un miliardo di volte un metro.
Vediamo chi ha scale più grandi.
Facciamo un altro salto
di un miliardo di volte.
Andiamo su una scala
di un miliardo di miliardi di metri.
Se prendete una sfera di questo diametro
arrivate a contenere più di 10.000 stelle
della nostra galassia.
Sono tutte stelle della nostra galassia -
quindi girano insieme al Sole
intorno a un centro comune,
il centro della Via Lattea.
Intorno a ognuna di queste stelle,
molto probabilmente, ci sono dei pianeti.
Lo sappiamo perché di questi pianeti
ne abbiamo già osservati tantissimi –
ne conosciamo ormai quasi 4.000.
Pianeti intorno ad altre stelle.
E queste stelle sono talmente lontane
che la luce che ci arriva da queste stelle
impiega decine di anni ad arrivare a noi.
Ed è in questo senso che l'astronomia
ci offre una sorta di macchina del tempo:
ci permette di vedere l'universo
come era nel passato.
Facciamo un ultimo salto:
siamo a un miliardo di miliardi
di miliardi di metri
ed arriviamo ai confini
dell'universo osservabile.
Non sono i confini dell'universo,
di tutto quello che esiste.
Probabilmente l'universo
è molto più grande:
potrebbe essere infinito,
per quanto ne sappiamo.
Ma questo è l'universo osservabile.
La luce che ci arriva da queste distanze
ha impiegato l'età dell'universo
per arrivare a noi;
quindi noi la vediamo come era,
vediamo queste regioni dello spazio
come erano poco dopo il Big Bang,
essenzialmente.
E questa, secondo me,
è una delle immagini più incredibili
che siano mai state prodotte
dalla scienza e dall'umanità.
È una fotografia dell'universo
nella sua infanzia,
prima che si accendessero le stelle
e prima che si formassero i primi pianeti.
Ci troviamo oggi,
per la prima volta
nella storia dell'umanità,
nella condizione di avere
una spiegazione scientifica,
convincente, precisa, dettagliata
dell'origine, della struttura
e dell'evoluzione dell'universo.
Il progresso scientifico, però,
ci ha messo di fronte
anche a qualcosa
di completamente inaspettato.
Abbiamo scoperto un universo
oscuro, misterioso.
Popolato di entità sconosciute,
di cui non sappiamo quasi nulla,
come la materia oscura
che sembra sostenere le galassie
come una sorta di impalcatura cosmica -
tutte le galassie, compresa la nostra;
o l'energia oscura che, invece,
sembra spingere l'espansione dell'universo
e farlo espandere sempre più velocemente.
E ci siamo anche dovuti confrontare
con le cosiddette singolarità.
Le singolarità sono dei punti
in cui la fisica nota, essenzialmente,
impazzisce, perde significato.
Sono singolarità come i buchi neri -
degli oggetti talmente estremi
da distorcere lo spazio
e il tempo intorno a loro,
che sono fusi insieme in un'unica entità
che si chiama spaziotempo,
secondo la teoria
della relatività di Einstein.
E come il Big Bang stesso:
se voi riavvolgete all'indietro
il nastro del tempo
arrivate a un istante
in cui, praticamente,
tutta la materia che esiste nell'universo
è concentrata in un punto
di densità infinita.
Questa è la frontiera della cosmologia
e queste singolarità sono quelle
che molti di noi - forse anche di voi -
hanno imparato a conoscere
grazie ai lavori del fisico inglese
Stephen Hawking, che è scomparso da poco,
che ha scritto un libro
molto conosciuto, molto popolare,
che si chiama appunto
“Dal Big Bang ai buchi neri”.
Questa è la frontiera
della cosmologia moderna:
in tutti gli istituti di ricerca,
nel mio istituto ad Amsterdam
e in tutti gli istituti
di ricerca del mondo,
stiamo cercando di capire
e di conoscere meglio
i misteri che sono racchiusi
in questi nomi
che diamo a cose
che ancora non capiamo bene.
C'è una cosa, però,
in comune a tutti questi misteri:
che sembrano affondare le loro radici
nell'infinitamente piccolo.
Questi misteri che osserviamo
sull'universo a grandissima scala
sembrano tutti affondare le loro radici
nella cosiddetta fisica quantistica -
la fisica che regola
l'infinitamente piccolo, il microcosmo.
Proviamo, allora, a vedere -
a fare il percorso inverso.
Abbiamo visto che cosa c'è
sulle grandissime scale dell'universo;
vediamo cosa c'è sulle piccolissime scale.
E partendo dal metro,
che è la nostra unità di riferimento,
andiamo a vedere che cosa c'è
su scale di un miliardesimo di metro.
Dentro ciascuno di noi,
dentro ciascuna cellula
del nostro organismo,
se guardate sulla scala
di un miliardesimo di metro
troverete la molecola
del DNA, per esempio;
tante molecole, in particolare
la molecola del DNA
che ha uno spessore
di 2 miliardesimi di metro.
Continuiamo a scendere in dimensione;
arriviamo a un miliardesimo
di miliardesimo di metro
e arriviamo a risolvere
quello che c'è dentro i nuclei atomici -
dentro ai protoni e ai neutroni
che stanno dentro i nuclei atomici.
La fisica che governa,
che regna in questo mondo,
è la fisica quantistica
ed è una fisica stranissima.
Vi faccio un esempio:
dentro i protoni - i protoni
sono composti, praticamente,
da tre particelle fondamentali
che si chiamano quark -
se voi prendete la massa
di questi tre quark
vi aspettereste che fosse uguale
alla massa del protone;
invece, la massa del protone
è molto più grande della massa dei quark.
La massa dei protoni è contenuta
non nella massa dei quark,
ma nell'energia che li lega insieme.
E secondo l'equazione di Einstein, E=mc2,
energia uguale massa
per velocità della luce al quadrato,
si manifesta come massa.
Quindi, tutto quello che vedete intorno -
il vostro stesso peso -
deriva da questi minuscoli nodi di energia
che sono contenuti in ciascun atomo
del vostro organismo.
Ecco, la cosmologia moderna
ci invita a cercare
la risposta ai grandi problemi
delle grandissime scale dell'universo
in questo mondo - nel mondo
della fisica quantistica.
A cambiare completamente
lo studio di questi fenomeni,
e a creare una sorta di ponte
tra infinitamente grande
ed infinitamente piccolo,
è nata, pochissimo tempo fa,
una nuova branca dell'astronomia.
Alcuni di voi ne avranno sentito parlare:
si chiamano le onde gravitazionali.
E queste sono importanti
perché ci permettono -
ci offrono delle informazioni
completamente complementari
a quelle che vengono portate dalla luce,
a qualunque lunghezza d'onda,
sulla terra.
Ci permettono, in particolare,
di ascoltare le vibrazioni
dello spaziotempo stesso
prodotte da oggetti che, altrimenti,
resterebbero per sempre nascosti
nelle tenebre dell'universo profondo,
come i buchi neri, per esempio.
Ed è proprio per questo
che il Premio Nobel per la fisica
è stato assegnato per questa
scoperta straordinaria nel 2017.
É come se, esauriti
i colori dell’universo,
l'umanità stesse sviluppando
dei nuovi organi di senso
per percepire l'universo profondo
e per conoscere l’universo.
È una frontiera straordinaria
della conoscenza
che sta nascendo proprio in questi anni.
E quello che stiamo cercando di fare
è di utilizzare queste onde gravitazionali
per stabilire questi collegamenti
tra l'infinitamente grande
e l'infinitamente piccolo.
Lo stiamo cercando di fare
con i buchi neri,
e abbiamo già osservato
la fusione di diversi sistemi,
di due buchi neri che si sono fusi
in un unico grande buco nero.
E questo ci sta permettendo
di capire tantissimo
sull'origine e l'evoluzione
dei buchi neri,
anche sui cosiddetti effetti quantistici
della fisica quantistica
che avvengono intorno all'orizzonte
degli eventi di questi buchi neri.
Stiamo cercando la firma
della materia oscura
intorno a questi oggetti,
intorno a questi buchi neri.
E forse, analizzando questa firma
riusciremo anche a capire
di che cosa è composta,
e identificare la natura
della materia oscura.
Potremo capire se l'energia oscura
è collegata veramente
all'energia del vuoto -
del vuoto quantistico –
che a differenza del vuoto classico,
che significa assenza di materia,
ribolle continuamente di attività.
E forse, in maniera
ancora più incredibile,
stiamo cercando le onde gravitazionali
prodotte dal Big Bang stesso,
e stiamo cercando
di verificare questa teoria,
assolutamente incredibile e vertiginosa,
secondo cui tutto quello
che esiste nell'universo
deriva da piccolissime
fluttuazioni quantistiche
che erano presenti
nell'universo primordiale.
Arriviamo, quindi,
alla fine di questo viaggio
tra infinitamente grande
e infinitamente piccolo
e vale la pena chiedersi:
cosa ne è di noi, di noi esseri umani?
Che ruolo giochiamo,
in questo grande spettacolo del cosmo?
Viene quasi da sentirsi piccoli,
irrilevanti, insignificanti
di fronte all'immensità del cosmo.
Se ci pensate, da Copernico in poi
siamo stati spostati:
prima eravamo - la Terra
era il centro dell’universo;
poi siamo stati spostati,
siamo diventati un pianeta
che gira intorno al Sole,
uno dei tanti pianeti
che girano intorno al Sole;
poi abbiamo scoperto che eravamo
uno dei tanti pianeti,
intorno a una delle tante stelle,
intorno a una delle tante galassie.
Ma il messaggio con cui
vi vorrei lasciare stasera
è esattamente l’opposto.
Secondo me, la fisica
e l'astronomia moderne
ci stanno dicendo in maniera chiara
che siamo speciali;
siamo fatti, noi esseri umani,
di una forma di materia
rara nell’universo.
Siamo come delle gemme incastonate
in questo mare di oscurità
che è l’universo.
Se ci pensate, siamo agglomerati di atomi
che riflettono sulla loro esistenza,
sull’esistenza dell’universo.
Una sorta di autocoscienza
e di autoconsapevolezza
dell'universo che si sta generando.
Ecco, vorrei che fosse questo
quello che penserete
quando stasera uscirete
a rivedere le stelle.
Grazie.
(Applausi)